to me is somebody who had grown up in
the mountains and loved the mountains
the idea that a coal company had the
right to blow up an entire mountain and
wipe it off the map forever was just
unconscionable these places are not just
sort of physically important to people
but they're spiritually important to
people and once they're gone they're
gone forever you can't put them out back
together and I just deeply feel that no
company has the right to take away
something that ultimately belongs and
matters to so many people just look
across the valley next-door that's what
it used to be like you know one of the
most diverse forests on the planet and
now it's wasteland over there used to be
a valley and a stream that's now covered
up with thousands of feet of boulders
that's never gonna be the same again and
it's over 2,000 miles of streams have
been buried in Appalachia some of the
most diverse streams on the planet some
of the cleanest water on the planet and
that is a huge loss to this this part of
the world
when that rock material is pushed over
the edge of the now flattened Mountain
it ends up dissolving a lot of minerals
into the water things like iron
magnesium calcium and organisms can't
tolerate that so it kills organisms in
the stream and so that material that
water that is now heavily polluted runs
out of the base of the valley fill into
streams and eventually into rivers below
they also store the mining waste in
these huge earthen dams and they're
holding back billions of gallons of
toxic sludge that's leaking into the
drinking water everybody's little pretty
much it's contaminated in one form or
another so I don't use water cook use it
to do the dishes but that's about it
because you can wipe the water off
there's a God that we tend to help out
around again he is that blonde from the
water he could take his water turn his
water on put it in a clear water bottle
put his hand over it sit up for a few
seconds you can put a cap on it take the
cap off and take a lighter and light it
in water order so yeah what a red
[Music]
Oh